There was a sort of meeting of the minds on
television a few days ago.
I don't know how the universe was able to
[inaudible]
the joining of purveyors of such big ideas
with big brains, but Donald Trump's personal
lawyer, Rudy Giuliani showed up on none other
than Fox and friends, and the video is simply
stunning.
Rudy Giuliani was so unhinged in this video
in the middle of the impeachment trial of
Donald Trump that the and friends people kept
trying to end the interview and interrupt
Rudy, but Rudy would not allow it.
It became an embarrassment for everybody involved.
Rudy, the day before the interview said he
had all this compelling evidence to provide
that.
The real story here is Joe Biden tried to
pull the Obama administration and Hillary
into something or other George Soros, all
this crazy stuff.
Everything other than Trump extorted utero
Ukraine to smear Biden.
Let's start just with some of Rudy beginning
not to make sense.
You'll see the totally biased audience is
still clapping right now.
Eventually they're going to completely glaze
over.
You'll see the looks on the faces of the hosts
starting to realize that Rudy Giuliani may
not be playing with a full deck.
Check out the shots of the crowd as well.
If you're watching, this is just the beginning.
I'm going to present over the next two to
three weeks, shocking crimes at the highest
levels of both governments.
While the Senate is listening to a totally
phony group of stories about non impeachable
offenses, it's like trying somebody for not
a crime.
It's a total waste of money.
It's a complete show on the part of the Democrats
and they should be sued for conspiracy to
defraud the United States and they should
pay for that hearing, but
may or do the democratic national committee
should play to that television advertising.
And you talk about interfering in the 2020
election.
You know, I started investigating Biden two
years ago when he was thinking about running
for president.
I never thought he would run.
So Rudy keeps getting more and more conspiratorial
and things start to get really weird and even
Rudy starts to lose his train of thought in
the middle of these weird things that he's
saying and the hosts are starting to get uncomfortable
and shifting in their seats and realizing
that Rudy's making no sense, and we've got
to be polite because it's Trump's lawyer,
but this is really going sideways.
In the middle of the corruption presentation,
one gentleman said to me, what you know about
the Biden bribe?
I said, what are you talking about?
He said, well, Biden, Biden got paid off and
he went to Poroshenko.
He forced a prosecutor out.
Not only did he get his son out, but he got
barista.
So one of the things we're going to reveal,
we always think, we always ask, why did this
happen?
Why would a crooked Ukrainian oligarchy whose
company is about to be taken away from him
who sitting in Switzerland with $5 billion,
he stole all, this is just fact.
His name is my colo.
Zillow.
Shefsky this is all true what I just said.
He hires the son of the vice president who
just got thrown out of the Navy for failing
a drug test had been in and out of rehab most
of his life.
So this continues for a while and I won't
play it all, but eventually the hosts start
to more successfully interrupt.
Here's another portion of it, and then you'll
see the hosts get involved.
None of it is making sense.
You'll see Brian Kilmeade try to stop Rudy,
but you can't stop Rudy.
You can only hope to contain him.
And then right after that is when Biden says
get rid of Shogun and Shoken will test tracking
will testify to that.
And I will show you a document that in September
of last year, Shoken was taken to the hospital
with mercury poisoning.
All right, so let me, let me just get a word
in.
I know what happens.
You know this happens in Ukraine and Russia,
right?
That's a choice has poisoning.
So let's just say that everything you say
proves a hundred percent truth is 100% you
also say, would you also say that the way
you approached it for the short term which
we're in the middle of has made things worse
for the, I would say the way I approach it,
it's for the benefit of the American.
People.
Notice the audience is completely out by now.
They don't even know what Rudy's talking about.
At first, they sort of understood Rudy was
saying things that sounded good to them and
they were clapping and cheering and they would
cut to the audience.
The audience has gone completely silent now
because they have no clue what Rudy's talking
about.
Here's Steve Doocy tries to jump in.
Rudy just won't let him and Rudy then loses
his train of thought again.
Steve Doocy tries to interrupt it two more
times.
Brian kill me, tries do, see tries again and
they just can't and even Ainslie Earhart is
trying to interrupt.
He is not prosecuted.
He is sitting there fat and happy with his
company and then we got another bribe.
You don't think the president of the Ukraine
shared in that $5 billion.
It's a crook kep Rudy, the bribe to the president
of the Ukraine.
The amount of money, uh, I can't be absolutely
sure.
Let's say let's say it's well in excess of
10 million off the entire crowd.
Now, that shouldn't be revealed from a lawyer
who finds out about this.
Am I going to cover it up the way the Democrats
and the media cover it up?
Absolutely not.
I prosecuted a too many corruption cases to
sit by and watch my country sold out by a
vice president who did a two on the times,
at least in China.
So how does this end?
Can you imagine?
No one has any idea what Rudy is talking about.
They have no clue.
Here's, do, see, again, just relentlessly
trying to put an end to this insanity.
They're coming after me.
Rudy would want to kill me.
Are you?
When are you going to present terms of reputation?
Pardon the interruption.
Shocking.
They're trying to really chill.
When are you going to present the evidence?
Because you're telling a compelling story
play today at noon.
So here it starts to seem like it's going
a little bit better and Rudy is kind of calming
down, but then it turns back around and Giuliani's
talking about George Soros and then the hosts
really don't know what hit them.
They start to look dazed.
You can kinda jump back into this anywhere
and it would make no sense no matter where
you started the video.
But let's look at another segment.
That's when they moved the ambassador and
they never bothered to investigate the allegations
that she interfered in for investigations,
that she
was campaigning for Hillary Clinton during
the 2016 election.
Ambassador, the ambassador that one of the
cases she had dropped was on George Soros,
his company and tack.
I didn't hear any of this yesterday, and tech
and tack was gathering dirty information on
Trump.
So this is about Liszewski and Poroshenko
and Hunter Biden and Joe Biden and Obama and
Hillary and George Soros.
But definitely none of this is actually about
Donald Trump.
The next moment is one of my favorites.
Rudy's cadence starts to suggest he's winding
down and you can see Steve Doocy spots the
window of opportunity opening where he might
be able to take control back of this nonsense,
but then Rudy just gets going again and the
hosts all looked dejected.
You think it's just Biden who was cashing
in in the Ukraine, and then every time you
hear the word Biden was Obama's point, man,
there's something that follows the Biden family,
makes millions of dollars they made, they
got an investment in a one point $5 billion
housing program in Iraq when Biden was named
plummet.
I've been on the wrong end of interviews like
this before where you simply cannot get the
guest under control.
This is 13 minutes in total.
Rudy is going on about everything from, there
are two bribes.
We'll actually know there are three bribes.
Two.
This is about George Soros to this is about
Iraq and the host can't get it under control
and the audience has been gone after minute.
Number two, notice the first two minutes the
audience was cheering the propaganda.
They have no clue what's going on.
They've stopped listening.
It's dead silent in there.
And then here's the last series of attempts.
And Steve Doocy has to have jokingly say,
um, you have to stop talking now by saying,
I'm sure you could go until noon.
Rudy and Ainslie Earhart laughs like it's
all fun and games, but the three of them look
like they're, I don't know how many of you
have seen the movie airplane from 1984 hilarious
movie.
There's a scene in airplane where the main
character, Ted striker is sitting on an airplane
and he starts telling these endless stories
to the woman traveling next to him.
And every time they cut to the woman, she
looks sicker and sicker to her stomach.
And ultimately she actually hangs herself
in the movie.
It's a joke.
And Ted striker is just continuing to tell
the story.
The hosts look like that woman.
And Rudy will not stop here, do see, finally
manages to end it.
And they don't get to her and say, what are
you kid, your son?
Your son's got a no show job for millions
of dollars.
You're in the pocket of slow Shefsky and you're
telling us not to be corrupt.
You know how that hurts the United States.
I a feeling you can go clear til noon when
your podcast starts.
Give it up for Rudy
[inaudible]
only the tip of the iceberg.
There are other people involved.
There's a lot more money.
There was a pattern of caution there and even
in ending it, Steve Doocy still, uh, can't
stop.
Uh, Rudy Giuliani from getting a little bit
more in there.
That podcast Rudy is hosting where he's gonna
give you all of this evidence.
That podcast really sounds like a fun listen,
right?
Does anybody agree with me?
Fox news, desperate to control Rudy trying
and failing for 13 minutes.
This should actually be exhibit a for journalism
classes in how not to allow the guests to
take control of the interview.
And unfortunately this happens to everyone.
We've had people on this show where I lose
control of the guest and we've had situations
where it ends up going 40 minutes and we end
up just having to remove an entire part of
it and say, we'll put that online.
And only using a fraction of it for the broadcast
show because of time constraints.
It's happened to me.
You almost start to feel bad for the three
hosts of Fox news because it's happening to
them.
Until you remember that they are the host
of Fox and friends and active participants
in being purveyors of endless dangerous pro
Trump propaganda, then I don't feel quite
so bad for them, but an incredible unhinge
off
the rails appearance by Rudy Giuliani.
Quick break.
We'll be back after that.